I'm feeling good you feeling good
feeling you I am here with Hillary
Clinton's favorite astrophysicist that's
true right I'm the only one she knows
but she did publicly say that counts it
counts she said it and in a public
setting it's a matter of public record
neil degrasse tyson you are the director
of the Hayden Planetarium in New York
City in New York City my first
planetarium as a kid really yeah and so
like I thought New York would make a big
deal of that kind of coming back to be
The Reckoning they didn't care but you
guys have a new space show opening yes
yes tomorrow
yeah weekend this weekend right right
it's called the dark universe what's it
about is about it's about know about
dark matter and dark energies and and we
can measure the existence of these
entities in the universe but we don't
know what they are what they're made of
or anything else about them other than
that they're sort of dark matter is like
most of the gravity of the universe add
up your gravity and earth and moons and
planets and stars it does not equal the
total gravity we see something is making
up the rest of that we don't know what
that is we call it dark matter then
there's another pressure in the universe
that is pushing on the vacuum of space
making the expansion of the universe
accelerate opposite the wishes of the
gravity itself we call that dark energy
we don't know what's causing it we don't
know anything about it other than that
it's there how do you make a show about
something we don't know anything about
that was a challenge that was a
challenge usually you make a space show
you the planetary space show with the
dome and you sit in the care that's what
I'm talking about yeah you go in there
and it's like here's what we know and
and you come out kind of smug yeah we
got that I got that and here it's not
our approach we're honest about our
ignorance and I think that's the that's
a it's an important place to be to fully
understand how science works and you I
have heard you say that you know the
more you understand the more questions
it opens up science its kind of
Stephanies yeah yeah and the poetic way
to say that is oh yeah I'm a larger is
your area of knowledge mm-hmm that grows
so too does the perimeter of your
ignorance that's what I said right
and I do want to help you bring more
awareness to the cosmos science and I
have three ideas I just want you to let
me know if you think they're good ideas
are better okay first one is a woman's
line of clothing called the zero g
string this wait list love it great
what do it check the other one is to
change the name of the Hayden
Planetarium to that hayden Panettiere 'm
oh you know did I
fans I tweeted about it you did yes
because I looked up Hayden Planetarium
you see how high it you know how many
hits it got on the on Google and I mean
how many how many references to the
Hayden Planetarium there are on Google
and then Hayden Panettiere panic tear
and yeah Panettiere he gives up the
penance so she had more internet pages
reference to her than the Hayden
Planetarium revelry yeah so third ID you
know she earned it
third idea is well well what's worse
than that is the Big Bang Theory sitcom
comes in higher in a Google search than
the Big Bang Theory origin of the actual
universe well I don't know if that's
good or bad it's do you know more about
both yeah I got a boat yeah third idea
turn this Hubble Space Telescope around
use it to take pictures of food and I
think people would like that it it is
engineering Lee no such word the
engineering of the telescope was
designed to prevent that from happening
so that the military would not co-opt it
prevent us from seeing the sky you guys
are smart we got that you got that well
I know thank you I'll let you get out of
here but you guys should really check
out the new space show dark universe at
the Hayden Panettiere no just a
planetary planetary and also star talk
live well you think you get a live show
on star talk live it's happening yeah
yeah the forest scene November 4th at
town hall at 8 p.m. check it out